this video is sponsored by the
personalized soundscape app endl the
first 100 people to click the link in
the description will receive one free
week of audio experiences
armand was just 14 when he first became
interested in mind uploading
the year was 2060 and up until this
point the idea had mostly been exclusive
to science fiction and futurist
speculation but now entering the second
half of the 21st century with quantum
computing becoming commonplace scanning
technology becoming high enough
resolution and with massive progress
being made in humanity's understanding
of the brain's entire system of
interactions and influences the prospect
of mapping a person's brain digitizing a
replica and uploading it to the cloud
was seemingly at least in theory on the
horizon
if achieved this technology would
potentially allow human minds to live on
indefinitely
[Music]
armand spent much of his free time in
early adolescence reading and learning
about this technology without even
really being conscious of it around the
same time he also started developing a
deep-seated anxiety about time itself
how for him and everyone he knew
it would sooner than later come to an
end
the more this reality set in the more it
unsettled him the more he resisted it
the more he lived in a fear-fueled
denial of it his consciousness capable
of thinking and creating and loving with
grand gesture only aware of what it
meant to exist and wired to cling to it
could not conceive of the prospect of it
eventually not existing forever
and so armand embarked on his
immortality project
in early adulthood armand would go to
school and begin a career as a computer
scientist and engineer his primary
interest being in streamlining quantum
computing and quantum optimization
algorithms during this time armand would
begin living completely differently
realizing more and more that in order to
achieve his desire of living forever he
would need to survive long enough for
the possibility of the technology to
become a reality at the time it was
believed that mind uploading technology
could potentially become testable on
human brains and somewhere around 30 to
40 years and likely available as an
option to the general public in around
40 to 60.
and so armand would begin leaving his
youthful haphazardness behind and move
more into a strategic careful
conservative lifestyle
initially this was made manifest mostly
through a hyper awareness of perfect
health habits exercising twice a day
curating a supplement regiment and
eating a perfectly clean optimally
balanced diet
however as our mon aged further into his
later 20s in an attempt to reduce as
much risk as he could he began isolating
himself more and more from the world
he began turning down invitations and
opportunities to go places and do things
concerts parties events vacations and so
on
if he wanted to live forever he realized
he would have to be disciplined he would
have to make sacrifices
throughout this time armand made sure to
keep a close eye on the companies
leading the path in the mind uploading
space doing plenty of research and
analysis based on his growing
understanding although these companies
were of course completely secretive
about their progress armand consistently
heard promising things from within the
industry and from industry experts and a
large number of people around the world
were living like armand for the same
reason
and so his desire and efforts continued
to burn
as more time would pass armand saw his
friends and family less and less only
really seeing them on rare circumstances
or in occasional vr chats
by his 30s he lost contact with most of
them after moving into a bunker shelter
property in a small isolated community
several thousand miles away in the
countryside he loved the city but he
realized he had to live somewhere safer
and more conservative he would
essentially remain here contained inside
his shelter for the rest of his life
only really keeping in contact with his
parents who would in a short time pass
away of old age
our mom would primarily focus on his
work which was now almost exclusively
done remotely he would have everything
he needed delivered to him and only go
out on rare occasions when necessary as
he continued to follow and become more
entrenched in the quantum computing ai
and mind uploading industry the tech
appeared to only be getting better and
better closer and closer
by this point more and more people were
living in careful preservation of
themselves awaiting the technologies
almost certain release
it appeared to be just a matter of time
before mind uploading was a real option
and armand believed with all his
conviction and knowledge that it was
inevitable
fueled by this our mom would essentially
sacrifice his social life his love life
his family life and arguably his life in
general
he continued to defer his happiness and
experience to later
he believed he would live forever and so
he lived as if he would
in the year 2133 when armand was 87
years old his lifelong desire finally
came into view
for the first time one of the companies
pursuing the mind uploading space known
as samsara revealed the release date of
the first ever publicly available
government sanctioned mind uploading
technology very little information had
been shared up until this point as all
companies kept the specifics of their
technology under strict ndas but now the
technology was set to be introduced and
released just following a product
introduction event scheduled on january
1st 21 34.
upon hearing the news armand was
overwhelmed with anticipation and
excitement
on january 1st he attended the event
virtually along with the crowd of
hundreds of thousands of people the ceo
of samsara stood on the stage and said
tombstones ashes and urns diamonds
pictures videos belongings and memories
for centuries these things have been
entrenched into human society as ways of
remembering and keeping our loved ones
with us after they're gone
but what if i told you you could
actually keep a version of them with you
what if i told you that friends and
family members can still feel like their
loved ones are here with them after
they're gone
with some sorrow mind uploading
technology this is now a reality
with absolute precision and accuracy we
can scan map and upload hyper-realistic
copies of any human brain and then place
it into any avatar which can then be
engaged and interacted with through all
major vr and ar applications just as if
it were a real person still here
of course like with all new
revolutionary technologies there are
some unexpected limitations
all testing indicated that all test
participants did not recognize the
continuation of a consistent selfhood
upon upload
the same sense of self appears to be
lost
and so the user will not recognize
themselves as themselves anymore because
they won't be
it is not obvious why there appears to
be something missing and it appears
impossible to compute or find
however the avatar will still be
reminiscent with utmost accuracy of the
original versions of their human a true
miracle of computer science
as the ceo continued to speak armand
realized what was happening
the ceo's voice and everything around
him fell out of focus as he became numb
his hope what he had waited and
sacrificed his whole life for wasn't
what he believed it would be
he had held out in hopes that once he
uploaded his mind life would finally be
worth living and now that he was going
to be able to do so he wasn't even going
to be there to enjoy it
armand felt his entire life drop out of
him he felt like a carcass of could have
been years would go by
armand was 94 years old he found himself
lying on his deathbed in a hospice care
facility
as the completionist he was and for no
other reason then why not he
preemptively opted in and qualified for
the samsara mind uploading service which
ended up being the best of any company
of the time
armand was asked what he would like his
avatar to look like and other questions
pertaining to its customization he
signed and filled out all the necessary
consent in waiver forms and when the
time was right his brain was scanned
mapped modeled digitized and it began
uploading into the cloud an upload bar
initiated on a computer screen that sat
next to him in his room
over the span of the following weeks the
upload bar filled more and more
throughout which armand became more and
more ill sleeping most of the days and
becoming increasingly delirious
on one of the days a young male hospice
nurse was in armon's room with him doing
a regular checkup while carrying out
standard checkup protocol armond began
making small helpless puffs of air with
his mouth armond everything okay the
nurse said
armand looked the nurse in the eyes
grandson
the nurse paused realizing what was
happening no armand i'm the nurse you
don't have a grandson remember
oh
a pause filled the room
grandson
armond continued to the nurse don't live
like me
okay
i spent my whole life avoiding death but
i have been dead for a long time
to live is to risk
what you do
what you do in response to that risk is
what separates the living from the dead
i see that now
in a huff armand returned to a delirious
silence
a few moments later these would become
his last words four days later the
upload bar and the computer screen
completed the samsara software
application screen opened and an avatar
of armand appeared
it looked just like him
confused and somewhat scared
naive
and desiring
this video was sponsored by endl
with life constantly moving around us
time pushing us forward through it and
the endless longing to move on to the
next or to be elsewhere it can be both
extremely difficult and extremely
important to intentionally calm down and
relax the mind there are various things
that can help do this but many of which
involve additional time effort
inconsistency or complete interference
with your routine
the soundscape app endl provides a
solution for better controlling your
mental states that is both highly
effective and integrates seamlessly into
your regular routine we all know the
value of listening to music throughout
the day to help focus calm down and so
on endle recognizes this how sound
impacts well-being and mental states and
optimizes it by combining scientific
understanding with cutting-edge
technology to create personalized
soundscapes that deliver consistent
controlled effects that can help you
relax focus and sleep endle uses
patented ai technology backed by
neuroscience studies that reacts and
adapts to real-time inputs like time of
day the weather your heart rate location
and more in doing so it better allows
you to synchronize with your
circumstances lifestyle and circadian
rhythm ensuring that at all times and in
all moods what you listen to matches
what you want to feel
if you're interested you can sign up
using the link in the description the
first 100 people to use the link will
receive one free week of audio
experiences
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you